With Pixel Watch, you can simplify your life...
...with the best of Google on your wrist.
Google's latest launch is taking aim at the smartwatch sector,...
...a field dominated by one of its main rivals, Apple,...
...at a time when inflation-hammered consumers...
...are shunning all forms of pricey wearables.
Priced at $350, the Alphabet Inc. gadget...
...costs $100 more than the lowest cost Apple model.
The other catch?
It's limited to people with Android phones.
That will open the wearable tech up to enormous obstacles...
...in terms of consumer adoption, according to market analysts.
Google apps already work with watches from companies...
...including Apple, Samsung Electronics and Fitbit,...
...which Google bought last year.
The new round-faced Pixel Watch enables contactless payments,...
...music control and turn-by-turn directions.
A model with cellular connectivity costs an additional $50.